cnn now cannot hide it anymore we've
been showing you a bunch of these over
the last couple weeks the people do not
like joe bite
tonight 75
the vast majority of democrats three out
of four don't want biden to be their
nominee in 2024. that is according to a
new cnn poll out front now david axelrod
former senior adviser to president obama
david i i heard that and sort of stopped
in my tracks for a second three quarters
of democrats don't want the incumbent
president to run again
uh how worried should
biden be right now about that
well i mean obviously this is a this is
a very unhappy uh bit of data for him
and i'm sure
you know it is concerning look you got
to remember cnn does not want to run
these things right they want to run
cover for him the last thing they want
is a faltering stammering disastrous joe
biden and a collapsing economy which
then could lead to the return of donald
trump or tyron desantis or any
republican or a red wave in the midterms
et cetera et cetera it's funny how they
operate of course you know that guy
david axelrod there he was an obama
senior aide right so it's like you're
bringing on an obama senior aide uh who
was obama's vp yeah that was joe biden
so it's like you're already having like
the insidious nature of all of this this
is exactly what the swamp is you bring
on a guy who kind of worked with the guy
he's supposed to kind of criticize but
you know he also likes and doesn't want
the other guy to win it's just it's just
so awful and i know you guys can see
through it it's easy enough